before you become an entrepreneur if
you're asking yourself are you ready
to be an entrepreneur you can almost run
a mental a b test with whatever work
environment you're in
at that moment so if you're working for
a company if i was working for cisco
i could say you know there's a certain
set of things i'm responsible for
but what if i had my boss's job what if
i had my boss's boss's job
what if i was the ceo of cisco every
decision that they're making what
decision would i make if i were them
what information would i look for what
environment would i create
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i'm honored with
raj de datta co-founder and ceo of
bloomreach
raj dadat is the co-founder and ceo of
bloomreach a leading software platform
for digital commerce experiences that
powers brands representing
25 of retail e-commerce in the us
and the uk raj is a multiple time
entrepreneur
before launching bloom reach he was
entrepreneur in residence
at more davido ventures served as
cisco's director of product marketing
and was on the founding team of telecom
company first mark communications
raj serves on the council for player
development for the u.s tennis
association
as a founder partner at seed stage
venture capital from founder collective
and an individual investor in over 20
startups he holds a bsn electrical
engineering with a certificate in public
policy and international affairs from
princeton university
and an mba with distinction from harvard
business school
raj de dada welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm so honored to have you here thank
you for taking time out of your busy
schedule to
be here with me how are you doing
michael it's great to be here with you
i'm doing great
i'm i'm i'm happy we're on the summer
here in uh california
wonderful uh roger you know when i when
i thought
and prepared for what we're going to
talk about it was very hard for me
because
there are so many things that i want to
pick your brain on and so many amazing
things that you've done
both either from the venture capital
perspective the entrepreneurial
perspective
and advisory perspective and now from an
e-commerce and leadership perspective
that
you know i'm going to do my best over
these 20 minutes to to satisfy my
my thirst for for for the knowledge here
and so so i'll i'll do my best but raj
just you know briefly co-founder and ceo
of of bloom reach
uh something that i'm personally really
excited to hear more about
on the council for player development
for the u.s tennis association
and you're also a founding founding
partner of the founder collective
uh you did both princeton university and
harvard business school
uh cisco's director of product marketing
an entrepreneur
as well and so it's way too many things
to cover but raj
take me back to to entrepreneurial
experiences
that that sounds like that's an innately
part of you
absolutely so you know at age 21 right
after i finished college
uh you know i was i was working first at
a research institution bell labs uh on
the east coast and then
later on on wall street and i was gonna
go back to business school
and i met you know two individuals who
said they were interested in starting a
telecommunications business in europe
and would i be interested in joining
them and so without ever having been to
europe which is where the business was
based i picked up and moved to europe
uh got one got to paris where i never
i didn't speak any french realized it
was impossible to get the business off
the ground there
got on the train and moved to london and
set up really the first
business that i was involved in starting
at 21 years old
and it was a broadband services business
in europe and
it was just a fantastic experience to go
through
young in one's career mostly because i
really didn't know what i was doing
and yet at the end of that three-year
stint or three and a half years that i
did that
i was totally convinced that i wanted to
spend my life being an entrepreneur
and so maybe the greatest gift i got
early was having clarity about what
not to try to pursue and what to pursue
tell me a little bit more about that
clarity you know a lot of young
entrepreneurs including myself are here
listening to this and you know one of
the things that i'm really passionate in
hearing is
is finding that clarity what was it
about that entrepreneurial experience at
21 hopping on a train moving from
different locations
that told jiraj that this this is your
mission this is what's going to make you
happy
well there were a couple things that
happened in that venture the first was
you know the people that i was partnered
with were 20 years older and they put in
a little bit of capital and so i assumed
they knew what they were doing
and actually what i found was they
didn't know a whole lot more than i
i knew at that time and so i you know i
realized
hey if i'm gonna trust anybody's bad
judgment it may as well be my own
so that was the first uh the second the
second thing
you know that happened through that
venture is the venture was i would say
was mildly successful but it was not
crazy successful and so it but at the
end of it i just love the work i love
the creation
i love the challenge i love the effort
and i just couldn't get out
of my head and i thought to myself well
if it's not a great success
and i still love it that's a sign of
something that you really want to do
with your life
right and so following that
entrepreneurial experience you actually
you know if you look through the journey
you it's not like you then went on and
dedicated your life to start to doing a
startup after startup you actually found
your position in different leadership
positions at
various stages of the ecosystem whether
it's in venture capital or advising or
working for a company like cisco as
director of product marketing
what was that about what was the
rationale for you yeah
i was living in london i uh it was the
it was a recession which is you know
2001 to 2003 and and i wanted to come
back to the us i came back to business
school
in the us and then uh i actually was
moving out to silicon valley to start a
company and i got an offer from cisco to
rule up my little venture
into cisco and that's really how i
became director of product marketing at
cisco was
accidentally in that process and uh and
i was really involved in building a new
venture within cisco
uh and so it was really an
entrepreneurial effort just mostly done
within the walls of cisco
and that was great too and mostly that
what was great about that is i got to
see scale
i got to see what it was like for the
ceo of cisco
to build something great to communicate
to build culture
to drive things into the market things
that i never learned
on my own as an entrepreneur at 21. and
so it was still a very different kind of
entrepreneurial experience that then
took me to
hey i was only at a venture capital firm
for a few months thinking of the next
new idea
to start so really you know i would say
over 20 years
i've really been an entrepreneur three
times first in my first venture at 21.
second you know uh in an early venture
that was acquired by cisco and then the
third was
was the company that i'm involved in
right now bloom reach
that leap from entrepreneur 21 then
business school
cisco director of product marketing
scale
one of the biggest the most amazing
companies in the world what was that
like
from you know an internal perspective
what was that leap like for you
yeah you know it was actually pretty
hard i would say because i was so used
to kind of doing things on my own that
coordinating with tens of thousands of
other people
and the go-to-market organization it was
i would say it was incredibly satisfying
when we were building the products
then when we had to take it out to
market it involved coordinating with
thousands of sales people and marketing
people and
who were selling lots of products and so
it was a great learning experience but i
also have to say i didn't love it
towards the end of my tenure at cisco
and it re-convinced me
to leave and get back you know uh
on on my to my entrepreneurial routes
right now are there things that i as
young entrepreneur for example can can
do to prepare mentally
or or you know grow maturely you know
because
you know in today's world we navigate
back and forth and it's becoming more
and more frequent
so what are things that young
entrepreneurs perhaps from your
experience you learned that you know
that i can do for myself to to even
begin playing that thought simulation
forward
well i think that's a great question and
and indeed i
i the way i i think about it is that
before you become an entrepreneur if
you're asking yourself are you ready
to be an entrepreneur you can almost run
a mental a b
test with whatever work environment
you're in at that moment so
if you're working for a company if i was
working for cisco i could
say you know there's a certain set of
things i'm responsible for but what if i
had my boss's job
what if i had my boss's boss's job what
if i was the ceo of cisco
every decision that they're making what
decision would i make if i were them
what information would i look for what
environment would i create
what choice would i make on a
competitive basis what markets would i
enter so
basically you can almost simulate in
your mind as if
you're the leader of the company and and
and then
ask all the questions that you know that
that leader is confronting
and see what conclusions you come to and
then watch over the period of time
what they do how it plays out in
comparison to what you decided in your
own mind
and when you run that a b test you'll
come to one of two conclusions well
you'll either decide it's really hard
for you to make those choices in which
case you're probably not well suited to
be an entrepreneur
because at the end of the day you only
have your own judgment or you'll decide
actually you trust your gut it's pretty
good you know you have a good sense for
how to make these choices
and then you're ready so i want to move
on to blue reach
you know an incredible company and i
can't believe you know when i'm even
reading this
that that you're helping power brands
that are representing 25
of the retail e-commerce in the us and
the uk but but before that
a personal question for me because i'm
just fascinated by this
you're on the council for player
development for the u.s tennis
association
and you know as an amateur player myself
and
follower of almost every tennis match
that's happening
how do you even get to that why do you
do that yes you know so tennis
was actually a big part of my life
growing up in the you know when i was uh
i grew up in the in the philippines i
grew up in southeast asia
and uh i played a lot of tennis you know
growing up and then eventually when i
got to college
you know i didn't get any kind of
scholarship but i was able to walk on
and play with the team
you know at the very bottom of the team
i would say you know for for the the
years that i was at princeton so
it was a very big part of my mental
makeup and i actually believe
that tennis and tennis has actually been
the best preparation for
entrepreneurship
because entrepreneurship is
fundamentally a problem-solving lonely
sport and that is exactly what tennis is
um
and so you know later on in life uh as
as i've had the good fortune of building
companies and and being out here
you know i got to know the leadership of
the player development uh
effort here in the us and if you know
much about american tennis
what you'll conclude is the women are
doing great and the men are doing
terribly
basically you know and for 20 years
there hasn't been a grand slam champion
and so there's a group
that's come together to try to change
that and it's it's always been a passion
of mine and so i was glad to be able to
contribute
you know to help support that mission
incredible incredible so co-founder and
ceo of bloom reach
third entrepreneurial experience
definitely i'm sure not the last one but
but but the current one which is making
a significant significant impact in the
e-commerce space
bloomrich what is that about yeah so
bloomreach i started bloomerh now over
10 years ago and the thesis was that ai
and machine learning technology was
being applied at that time by google and
facebook
mostly for advertising but no one i i
knew was excited about going online
because they were interested in ads
you're interested in experiences you're
interested in
shopping and buying and meeting and
reading and all of these sorts of things
and so my
initial insight was let's use that class
of technology to make every website
every app in the world amazing for end
users
and in so doing drive a lot of revenue
for the brands that are publishing those
experiences
in that process and we we honed in on
e-commerce quite early on
and e-commerce became it became very
clear that
that you can't manually curate an
e-commerce site when you've got
thousands hundreds of thousands or even
millions of products and hundreds of
thousands or millions of customers
it's a grand matching problem that only
algorithms can play a role in
in in mapping and that's really what got
us started with bloom reach and so today
you know now fast forward 10 plus years
bloomer each is all about driving growth
for e-commerce companies and it's our
central thesis that the way you do that
is you either engage more customers to
your brand and we have an
engagement offering that does that you
inspire and educate them with great
content about your products and services
and then once they've decided to buy you
help them find the right product really
fast and so we have a discovery offering
that helps make that happen and when
these three things come together they
drive revenue for e-commerce brands
you know up and to the right and we've
had the good fortune of working with 750
of them
that lead on our platform to make that
happen
incredible now you don't settle just to
to run a startup in the e-commerce space
you actually
proceed to try and become a domain
expert in the space right right in fact
write a book about it right
that's right you know and there's a
story behind that which is that sort of
after doing this
after bloom reach and i'm also a seed
stage investor in
20 or 25 startups through my efforts i
would always get
the question from uh from folks that's
that would say why do the winners win
in e-commerce and in digital and why do
the losers lose
and so this book which is called the
digital seeker and it's now
out you know on amazon or you can go to
bloomereach.com and find it
is my attempt to answer that question
and and what i found that was
fascinating was that great
e-commerce experiences great digital
businesses
they build for the seeker not the
customer
and that's a little bit counterintuitive
because we've heard about customer
centric marketing or customer centricity
now for
many many years so what exactly what
exactly is this mythical seeker
and and the seeker is the why behind the
customer and so to use an example
you know i might be a customer of
plywood i want some plywood because i'm
looking to build a deck
and so you know when i go to the home
goods store i'll be looking for plywood
or then maybe i'll be looking for nails
and hammers and other tools
then maybe i'll be looking for paint or
whatever the set of materials are so i'm
a
customer of a paint company a plywood
company
you know a construction materials
company but i'm a seeker
of a great place to host barbecues for
my friends
and so the seeker is the person behind
the customer
and really what we do is we translate
our underlying motivations
into a into a digital to-do list and
then we become a
customer of 10 possible companies and it
turns out if you actually build
digital experiences for the underlying
motivation that's actually how you win
big and digital and so in category after
category
and we can talk about a number of
examples in healthcare
and in travel in uh transportation
the winners end up building you know for
the seeker
and not the customer right and so
how does one make that transition
because it's not trivial you're
essentially
adding an additional layer it's like in
you know moving from two-dimensional to
three-dimensional you're adding
you know an exponential amount of
complexity to the equation
and understanding how do you even go
about
trying to make that transition it's it's
um it starts with asking a lot of why so
let's let's
use an example we all know like uber
uber didn't say
how do i build a smarter taxi they said
well what is it that the person is
really seeking and they concluded the
person is seeking getting from point a
to point b
in a predictable fashion with
deterministic pricing
you know and a good car you know in a
predictable time frame
and so uber doesn't define itself as a
taxi company defines itself as a
transportation company that gets you
from point a to point b
and so in thinking about that they then
had to invest in mapping software
in payments in drivers in marketplaces
in reviews a whole series of things
but to start with you have to have the
insight about what the seeker is seeking
and data plays a key role in that as you
watch what people are clicking on what
they're buying what they're engaging
with
you can you can understand what they're
really seeking and you couple that with
qualitative evaluations and you'll get
to the root of the motivation
and then from that motivation that's
when
great technology and a great sort of
organizational structure and business
model come together
and then you build these moats you know
and what what i
what i'll leave people with on this
topic that i think is really interesting
is
you know i've seen bayern munich do this
in soccer i've seen
the national health service in the uk do
this in healthcare
i've seen stitch fix do this in fashion
this is not a story of silicon valley
startups
this is a story that any business that's
looking to win in digital can
ask that question i've seen uh an
amusement park do this really
effectively to compete against disney
world
and so you can you can apply this the
seeker-centric thinking
really to any domain now from a
leadership perspective
you know it's one thing to have that you
know that understanding and it sounds to
me like it's not just a
you know a textbook playbook of how to
go about asking these questions you have
to both be curious but you also have to
really be intentional
and in seeking for for those seeking
questions
how do you know as a leader help both
your people at bloomridge but also the
the companies that you invest in help
ask those questions but truly
intentionally
seek for the answers and not just do a
check box here
we found the answers from our customers
yeah
well i i i think a good test and there
actually
is a test in in the book where you can
ask how do you build a seeker-centric
business
a lot of it is asking you know
continuing to ask yourself whether
you're delivering the full experience
that that individual is looking for or
just a small part
you know of that because in a very
crowded internet if you're just
delivering a very small part it's very
easy for them to switch
from point a to point b so you know
you've arrived at a seeker-centric
experience
when it's very hard for a competitor to
compete with you because you've
marshaled all kinds of things so as a
leader
it's really asking the the usual hard
questions you know
what is why is somebody interested in
our product what are we uniquely
offering
you know to them that that is different
who within our organization is chartered
with assembling that experience
is critical as well it's it's a
different formation of team
you know in terms of of how you set that
up so there's a number of
critical questions i think you can ask
to get there
right and i think from from a naive
perspective it sounds to me like one of
the biggest challenges here is that
you're actually asking for people to go
beyond just the
just the initial success so it's not
enough for me to get people to go on my
website and buy my product
because to me for or maybe for a lot of
people that would be that that's the end
result that that's the success but
you're actually saying no
it's actually one step beyond that and
it's actually understanding why did they
buy the product
because otherwise you're not going to
stay for for too long perhaps
that's right you know what i mean to use
a simple financial metric
very often e-commerce businesses are
focused on sales and maybe margin or
profitability
but really we're moving to a world of
lifetime value
so you know when peloton sells you the
peloton it's not done right they sell
you the subscription after that
they're upselling you the packages after
that that is what e-commerce looks like
in the future
it's the lifetime value of that of that
end user that you're optimizing for
raj 20 minutes honestly have never gone
by so fast
this is this was just incredible i have
three short fun
questions that i want to get to know you
better so i'm just going to shoot them
at you and i'm curious to see the
responses
going back to middle school and high
school what would be a favorite subject
of yours
yeah so i i was always very interested
in in social studies and world history
and uh civics and things of that type in
fact i got a degree later on in public
policy in addition to engineering
and i was always very interested in
those topics
but also but also the connection between
and science and math amazing
and a a role model somebody that
inspires you
you know from a business perspective i
think i've always felt like the greatest
business leader of our generation is
jeff bezos
and and the reason i say that is other
people have built great companies
but retail is an incredibly low margin
business
very hard and so there's a reason why
you know he registered relentless.com
because i think that's what it takes to
build a be a great entrepreneur is
incredible perseverance and and
relentlessness and i think that's what
he's demonstrated
over and over again amazing and
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
you know um let me say what i tell my
kids all the time is dadas never give up
and so i think persistence uh is is
number one
number two is is strength uh i think you
know through adversity as an
entrepreneur
that's something that i take a lot of
pride in and the third is
straightforwardness
to just be able to call it like it is
raj this was amazing thank you so so
much
best of luck with the bloom reach and
like i can't wait to continue getting
inspiration and
definitely reading the book and it's
just thank you for these 20 minutes this
is just awesome thank you
michael it's been great thank you so
much
you